vamos con el problema 4 aquí nos ponen
un teorema y dice un triángulo tiene a
lo más un ángulo obtuso ok
eduardo está probando el teorema de
arriba por contradicción es decir va a
suponer que el teorema es falso y va a
intentar reducir algunas cosas con otros
hechos conocidos para llegar a una
contradicción bueno vamos a seguir
leyendo
eduardo comienza suponiendo que en el
triángulo abc los ángulos en a y en vez
son ambos obtusos déjame seguir por acá
la prueba de eduardo para que luego
sepamos qué hacer entonces tiene un
triángulo vamos a poner que este vértice
es a el de acá es b ya que es b y el de
acá ese entonces está suponiendo que el
ángulo en nada es mayor a 90 grados
esa es la es la definición de que algo
se auto uso de que el ángulo sea obtuso
y que el ángulo en b también mayor que
en 90 grados ok vamos a seguir leyendo
dice que teorema debe usar eduardo para
llegar a una contradicción ok entonces
debe usar algún teorema en vez de leer
las opciones vamos a pensarlo primero
vale
tenemos como herramientas cuando tenemos
un triángulo y nos dicen cosas acerca de
los ángulos para un triángulo cualquiera
pues esto de que la suma de los ángulos
en un triángulo es de 180 grados déjame
ponerlo por acá el ángulo en a más el
ángulo en b
más el ángulo en ce por supuesto sus
medidas esto de aquí tiene que ser igual
a 180 grados muy bien entonces vamos a
ver que podemos deducir a partir de aquí
a ver voy a pasar el ángulo en ay en
ángulo en b y el ángulo en b a la
derecha es decir voy a restar de ambos
lados del ángulo en hay el ángulo en b
entonces el ángulo en c es igual a 180
grados menos el ángulo en sada - el
ángulo en b y esto lo podemos reescribir
como que el ángulo en c simplemente son
formas de reescribir esto es igual a 180
grados menos el ángulo en a más el
ángulo en b ok pero eduardo que está
suponiendo pues que el ángulo en nada y
el ángulo en b ambos son mayores a 90
grados y si ambos son mayores a 90
grados que pasa con la suma bueno pues
la suma es mayor a 180 grados
pero entonces observa qué sucedería aquí
si ambos ángulos son obtusos entonces la
suma le gana a 180 grados y entonces
sería 180 grados menos algo más grande
que 180 grados y por lo tanto se sería
un ángulo negativo el ángulo en ce sea
de aquí se sigue
que el ángulo en ce es negativo pero
esto es imposible porque en un triángulo
no podemos tener ángulos negativos bueno
esta sería la demostración porque esto
ya nos permite concluir que entonces es
imposible que ambos ángulos sean obtusos
pero vamos a ver si podemos encontrar
esto que hicimos en las palabras que nos
dan en las opciones saber ha sido sang
los son iguales entonces los lados
opuestos a estos ángulos son iguales no
eso no suena lo que hicimos aquí ve si
dos ángulos suplementarios son iguales
entonces cada ángulo de 90 grados bueno
esto es cierto sí o sea si dos ángulos
son suplementarios entonces suman 180 si
son iguales cada uno es de 90 pero
tampoco usamos eso de este lado
el ángulo más grande de un triángulo de
supuesto al lado más largo no tampoco de
la suma de las medidas de los ángulos de
un triángulo 180 grados y si esto es
justo lo que utilizamos de hecho es la
primera línea que escribimos verdad es
ésta de acá entonces lo que necesita
usar eduardo es de la suma de las
medidas de los ángulos de un triángulo
es 180 grados bueno vamos al problema
número 5 a ver qué nos dice usa la
demostración dada para responder la
pregunta bueno vamos a ver cuál es la
demostración entonces nos dicen que está
dado que el segmento ave es congruente
al bc muy bien déjame marcar ave ave es
congruente a veces o sea estos dos
segmentos tienen la misma medida lo voy
a marcar así nos dicen que de es punto
medio de hace de es punto medio de hace
entonces a de mide lo mismo que dice lo
voy a marcar con este color rosa con
este color rosa ok y a partir de eso nos
piden mostrar que el triángulo ave de a
20 es congruente al triángulo cbd
se ve de ok que dos triángulos son
congruentes o sean congruentes quiere
decir que todas sus partes
correspondientes son iguales vale o sea
básicamente uno es igualito al otro solo
que podemos reflejarlo rotarlo o
trasladarlo cuando dos triángulos son
semejantes solo deben tener la misma
forma pero pueden tener diferente tamaño
pero cuando tenemos dos triángulos
congruentes bueno claro que son
semejantes tienen la misma forma pero
además sus lados correspondientes deben
de medir lo mismo y claro podemos
reflejarlo rotarlo de hecho parece ser
que abed y cb de que uno es el reflejo
del otro entonces a simple vista parece
ser que son que son congruentes pero
vamos a ver que que más nos dicen saber
entonces se supone que están haciendo
aquí una una demostración nos ponen un
enunciado y la razón entonces ab es
congruente abc y despuntó medio de hace
porque porque es esa información dada
claro ab congruente abc y de punto medio
de hace claro ese sí información dada
entonces esto está está bien
luego ade es congruente hace de el
segmento a d es congruente al segmento c
de esto es por definición de punto medio
si eso es lo que ya marcamos verdad ade
congruente hace de muy bien punto número
3 b d es congruente a b d pues claro
verdad ese es el mismo es el mismo
segmento entonces este de aquí es
congruente a sí mismo y aquí la razón
que nos dan es la propiedad reflexiva
guau eso está súper sofisticado para una
idea tan sencilla pero bueno propiedad
reflexiva enunciado 4
el triángulo abdou abdel es congruente
al triángulo cb de cvd ok eso es lo que
queremos probar y aquí ponen un signo de
interrogación
bueno vamos a ver que nos piden entonces
dice aquí qué razón se puede poner para
concluir que los triángulos son
congruentes a ok tenemos que llenar este
espacio de acá bueno pues como vimos
aquí arriba ya tenemos ya tenemos que
este lado el ave es congruente al bc el
cde es congruente al de a y el b d es
congruente a sí mismo entonces estos dos
de aquí son dos triángulos dos
triángulos que tienen los mismos tres
lados
entonces podemos concluir que ambos
triángulos son congruentes y cuál es la
razón de esta congruencia pues es el
criterio lado lado largo vamos a ver si
podemos encontrar eso hacia abajo
aunque ya mira el criterio ángulo ángulo
lado dos ángulos y el lado
correspondiente ángulo lado ángulo es el
dos ángulos y el lado entre esos dos
ángulos lado ángulo lado es dos lados y
el ángulo entre esos este dos lados y
finalmente criterio lll que es justo el
que utilizamos verdad estas tres cosas
nos prueban que los tres lados
correspondientes son congruentes y
entonces por el criterio lado lado lado
de congruencia déjame ponerle aquí que
es lado lado lado lado y lado lado lado
concluimos que los triángulos abc y cbs
son congruentes muy bien entonces aquí
la respuesta sería b todavía tenemos
tiempo para hacer otro más entonces
déjame pasar aquí abajo problema número
6 dice en la siguiente en la siguiente
figura tenemos que ave es mayor que bc
ave ave es mayor que veces bueno aquí en
la figura aparecen iguales pero no hay
que dejarnos llevar por las apariencias
nos dicen que ave es mayor que se vale
bueno vamos a seguir leyendo si asumimos
que la medida en a del ángulo a es igual
a la medida del ángulo ce entonces
déjame marcar
este de acá y si es congruente este de
acá básicamente que dos ángulos tengan
la misma medida es que son congruentes
escribieron esto pero también pudieron
haber escrito el ángulo en a es
congruente al ángulo en sí es
exactamente lo mismo vale bueno déjame
seguir leyendo entonces si asumimos que
estos dos ángulos son congruentes se
sigue que ab es igual a veces la medida
ave es igual abc claro verdad si tenemos
dos ángulos que son congruentes entonces
los lados opuestos son congruentes pero
está raro porque aquí tenemos otra cosa
bueno voy a seguir leyendo entonces dice
esto contradice la información dada de
qué ave es mayor que se claro porque ya
nos habían dicho que éste le gana a éste
pero ahora resulta que son iguales ya
que van con todo esto entonces nos
preguntan qué conclusión podemos obtener
de esta contradicción aunque lo que
están haciendo aquí es darnos una prueba
por contradicción entonces aquí
obtenemos una contradicción porque
encontrar aquí y obtenemos una
contradicción con la información
original entonces dónde está el problema
bueno entonces como están haciendo esta
prueba por contradicción están
suponiendo
que la medida del ángulo es igual a la
medida del ángulo en sí de ahí se sigue
que ave es igual a bs y de ahí se sigue
la contradicción entonces bueno este
paso de aquí es correcto suponiendo que
estas medidas son iguales podemos
concluir que estos dos segmentos miden
lo mismo y por supuesto es correcto que
esto contradiga la información entonces
dónde debe estar el problema debe de ser
en esta suposición inicial en que la
medida del ángulo en a es igual a la
medida de la ambulancia al pasar esto
pasa que a b es igual a veces eso
contradice la hipótesis inicial y por lo
tanto lo primero que asumimos debe de
ser falso entonces entonces lo que nos
dice esta contradicción es que la medida
del ángulo a el ángulo a debe ser
distinta a la medida del ángulo del
ángulo c vamos a ver si estas son las
opciones medidas de ángulo en nada es
igual a la medida de ángulo en b no eso
eso no tiene nada que ver
medida de ángulo en a es distinta de la
medida en ángulo en b eso se parece un
poco más pero todavía no son los ángulos
correctos la medida del ángulo
a la dc no eso es justo lo contrario
verdad verdad no podemos llegar a esa
conclusión más bien llegamos a lo
contrario son distintos y eso es justo
lo que dice de la medida del ángulo en a
es distinta a la medida del ángulo en sí
y entonces tenemos que la opción
correcta es de muy bien vamos a dejarle
hasta aquí nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo para hacer más de estos problemas